dr. Wallace thank you for your
invitation and good afternoon this is
really a great privilege and honor to be
invited here to share some of our health
disparity research with Asian American
communities and as we know asian
americans has a dramatic increase in
terms of its demographic trying to move
forward on this one the right that's
what I did doesn't present ok twice
present or so and you know there is in
general public there's a Miss perception
of asian-americans as a model minority
and when the to take further look at
about this demographic and also the
minority populations Asian is one of the
fastest-growing population in the United
States there about 30 million 50 cent in
the US it is an estimated that about 20
million in by 2020 so this will be
around eight percent of the u.s.
population and this is also the second
largest foreign-born group which also
have many of them coming from China
India Korea Philippine as well as
Vietnam there is a radio culture and
language differences this is the most
diverse population there about over 100
Asian languages and
spoken in the US by this asian
population and majority of them speak
another Asian language and a home
besides English and which has really
given a lot of indications about how we
deliver a health care system and with
this populations geographic distribution
majority of them live or reside in west
or east coast and especially in a large
cities of San Diego New York City LA
Houston and Philadelphia and in terms of
age group of this population and it is
relatively younger than the general
population and also education wise was
trying to going back up error okay here
we go in education it is really also
have a quite a bit of diversity in the
different Asian groups say education
level are very different Southeast
Asians have the highest high school
dropout rates and in terms of college
education d nummies is about fifteen
percent and if you go to other Southeast
Asians is about five percent and in
terms of income and poverty level this
population also some groups has a higher
poverty level than the general
population one of the areas that we have
been focusing on for many years is
located cancer health disparities among
asian american populations and
especially our certain cancers that are
a lot more experience in this population
let's see 20 min bank
maybe I'm not pressing hard enough stuck
there any help it doesn't work okay can
we go back I quite yet back murder look
at the previous one yeah okay and asian
population has experienced the third
highest incidence rates of breast cancer
colorectal cancer as well as long cancer
and this population also experience the
highest incidence and mortality rates of
liver cancer as well as stomach cancer
and there are certain high are highly
high prevalence of the dynasty related
liver cancer so there's this disease are
not especially liver and the stomach
cancers my related is not very much
higher in other general population and
this instance has reflected in this data
and in terms of cervical cancer we
enemies when they have a five times
higher incidence and mortality rates and
koreans also twice incidence rates among
the general population san thomas lennon
work is making the fluence to
ok here we go and look at further
regarding some grooves and the asian
population also experienced divers rates
and with japanese as well as Koreans and
South Asians and Chinese they have a
much higher breast cancer incidence
rates than other groups in terms of lung
cancer and knowledge is there's no mom's
here ok move back yeah it's go back yeah
well I was gave that for lung cancer
rates actually on it is higher than all
Asian groups especially among Vietnamese
Koreans Filipinos and Chinese that is
very much smoking related and as we know
oftentimes if you look at the national
data and the smoking race is not very
high there is actually some issues
related to the national data collection
because most of the time these studies
national studies which english speaking
asian populations so the non-english
speaking agents actually have much
higher smoking rates this is one of our
recent studies have trying to look at on
the early detection in different type of
cancers among various Asian ethnic
populations and also health checkup and
especially among Chinese Korean
Vietnamese and a Cambodian population
and if we take a look at just on these
few cancer early detection and you can
see even among the Korean pop
about 60 or 50 cent or fifty five
percent of them have not had health
check-up over five years had five years
ago I never had and if you take a look
at further of breast cancer cervical
cancer this that never screaming wait or
five years ago ahem down swinging is
also very high this there is a variation
among various groups if you look at a
rectal cancer a never screening rate is
high among all of these groups so this
gave us a sort of a baseline of where we
take in in terms of cancer detection
alright because you can't move on next
one and Asian populations they also
experience a large different type of
barriers which has prevent them from
health care services or access
healthcare services especially related
to the issues new immigrant population
the target population would deal with
ninety percent of them are new
immigrants specifically as primarily in
the east coast area washington d.c there
are Pennsylvania New Jersey and New York
City so these populations have specific
characteristics and that we have to deal
with and the other barriers related
unfamiliarity our healthcare system and
the healthcare system oftentimes is not
prepared to deal with these population
because of language issues because of
culture differences and other on related
barrier and the issues related to
language often times we see the patience
or the participant we work with high
English limited English proficiency and
transportation is also an issue lack of
health insurance and distrust with the
ministry health system and the other
parties is the non fully understand what
their rights are as well as their
benefits so this is really give us a
good opportunity often times to provide
intervention for the population and also
help them overcome of the different
barriers when this information in in in
mind we have respond this unease in the
Asian population okay yeah all right
this study really indicates the asian
populations has experienced the highest
difficulty in communicating with
healthcare providers especially
combination of care in cancer and other
health disease
in respond to in response to the needs
of our Asian community and we have taken
action in number of areas in two
thousand we have received funding from
an age and established a car special
population that org this is a regional
network that focus on different not only
on the smoking but also various cancer
issues in the same year we establish the
first Asian Community Cancer Coalition
in in two thousand that we need to go
back his too fast and you go back you
went to apartment he went all the way
boy
I just keep going next one okay keep
going sorry about the survey earlier
here where your we're not the next
previous one yeah you can we get a
larger or that's pretty much maybe we
just yeah maybe just stay this way sort
of just okay then okay then in 2003 we
have extended the Center for Asian
health to New York site as well as to
two sides in China and 2005 we
established continuing spending the
regional network of Asian community
cancer than work this network is
consisting of over 65 community-based
participatory organizations 35 health
care providers and many research
institution collaborators this is an H
and C I funded in master two years we
received the r 12 r was focusing on art
from the mice price of cervical cancer
in Asian American communities surround
the region and also a master September
we received our own to conduct a
randomized trial on hepatitis B related
liver cancer intervention in Asian
American communities so these are sort
of a few milestones I would like to be
more specific about the issues how we
have responded to the community needs
this doesn't like me ok next one
we can look at this index this is the
next one yeah I'm so sorry just came
running to know bank and so the target
population that we have been working
with of my beret the Chinese Vietnamese
Cambodian entry and underserved and
other underserved Asian Americans
Kuechly okay it's nice to one yes bit of
it up and down up and down okay okay
it's hard to the population we have
focused on our chinese population Korean
and Vietnamese and a Cambodian as well
as other underserved asian populations
such as mom ocean and also Asian Indian
populations and we have a team of
multilingual staff or having in
different area of the region and this is
our network geographically in the Asian
community cancer network
washington d.c Pennsylvania New Jersey
in New York City we do have a new office
in my hatton which as being primarily
serving the Chinese and Korean
population this is our headquarter in
Philadelphia and here i mentioned about
our work also has expended to on China
we have two sides currently we focused
on an intervention is smoking as well as
a breast cancer sissy's not working
that's what I'm tonight up some working
okay there we go it had longer maybe
smarts like yet so the major approach
that were taken is to reduce cancer
health disparities through education
research training early detection and
care and survivorship so all of our
programs are incorporating all various
components I think dr. de Clementis talk
really has made a very sound of
groundwork and a framework of what we're
doing and I think education is very
important and sometimes you can buy the
knowledge doesn't mean you're going to
change their behavior so we do research
to time to test various cultural
e-tailer interventions to see how this
can be more effective when for the
Chinese Korean
of ammonia each population has its own
unique culture and characteristics so it
is a continuum of our intervention these
are the sort of the majors three domains
or three on departments we have at our
center and we have a strong focus in
cancer primarily and cervical cancer
breast cancer of Morocco hepatitis B
related liver cancer bone cancer as well
as no state cancer the other areas that
we have focused on some chronic disease
of hypertension diabetes and heart
disease as well as osteoporosis the
third focus of our center is on tobacco
I like to elaborate a little bit more of
how we have done in these programs for
example in the breast cancer program
oftentimes we take the first step of
reaching the community and apartment
with the community leaders and various
partners but most important part we are
trying to use and adapt and also
included complete culture cultural
considerations into the intervention
program trying to change their knowledge
as well as beliefs and attitudes and we
also try to use ecological model to
change the system or to provide your
facilitators and to help participants
have better access to the health care
services so not only we provide
education but also provide navigation
and two to help participants all calm
the barriers in the healthcare system so
the own of most of these studies are
increasing the early intervention early
detection of breast cancers
Oh cancer colorectal cancer hybrid is B
and all these are going through a
continuum from education to patient
navigation as well as helping them in
the coating process if they were
identified as of normal cases this is
enormous effort oftentimes collaborating
with the healthcare partners as well as
community organizations and some of our
programs have already demonstrated
promising results especially as dr.
Gribben deployment it mentioned often
times when you in adapt and include
culture factors you will also increase
the effectiveness at the individual
level as well as move around level so
these are sort of our major on effort in
the continuum and so is with a smoking
cessation with a smoking cessation
program we have been trying to tailor
toward an individual as well as an
organizational level and oftentimes we
have to serve very appropriate under
realistic goals whether cessation is the
only aim and or you know quit attempts
so we use a very outcome variables for
these different programs these are some
of examples of our outreach and a
program in the community when we started
our initial programs these are sort of
the first step and also we provide
individual individual interventions and
education in the community as a group
smoking cessation and individual level
for smoking cessation each of these
programs are delivered in the Asian
witches as well as tailored toward
individuals needs at different stages so
these are a Chinese Korean Vietnamese
smoking cessation program in these are
some of the examples of our on trying to
go back these are examples of our cancer
education program in the Chinese Korean
Vietnamese Cambodian communities in in
the Philadelphia as well as New York
City and in the region so we provide
these education in partnership with the
community organizations and also in
providing training not only for the
participants but also for the community
partners
it's crazy
alright this is the example of our
patient navigation where as I mentioned
the healthcare system it is not ready to
really serve the Asian population
oftentimes the translation line is not a
really very effective so
person-to-person navigation is very
critical to overcome the barriers to
provide a clinical support and this
become one of the critical component in
our intervention and often times this
will increase the effectiveness of the
program this is the example of our
patient navigator or is helping the
patients conducting the mammogram and
also if there's a normal cases of
navigators also help them getting
further evaluation for the diagnostic
testing as well as as well as follow-up
treatment so these are the components
were look at not only an individual
level but also at a system level family
support so it's a lot more as a
ecological approach to incorporate into
all these interventions I wanted to sort
of sheer some of these programs that
have demonstrated some promising i'll
come for example our cervical cancer
program in of enemies in a korean
population has already demonstrated
effective outcome in the intervention
program we have observed the screening
rates from baseline thirty two percent
to ninety eighty percent and also we
have observed the hybrid high speed
program intervention and also the all
come from intervention group we observed
a baseline swinging at twelve percent to
they are six times follow-up of sick of
88 @ % our smoking intervention quit
program trial have also demonstrated
various outcomes in terms of smoking
quit rates about forty to sixty percent
so these are sort of examples of some of
our intervention that has been going on
over the past years in terms of the
future directions as a nation and I
think a continuum of intervention is
very important often times we've seen
their health Fair's there on outreach
activities sustainability is very
important and especially at the time
when resources are very limited and I
think long-term commitment and all
levels individual community and also the
scientific community and health care
providers is essential for the success
of serving this population and i would
like to also thank our that work who
have made contribution to the success of
all these programs as well as the
contribution to the health of Asian
communities so I'd like to sort of open
up for some questions and sorry about
the technical difficulties here we are
Jessica thank you for sure
okay so are there any questions for dr.
ma observations comments occasions oh
thank you dr. Locke or a presentation it
was very informative I just want to a
department after your forgiveness
enhanced by sound even praises and
discussions check first off are I am
acutely aware of the fact that ECE
agents for the most part as the model
donington yes the excitation is a most
of our lots of thinking about is that
they're highly educated highly educated
and a social economy services someone I
our expectation is that social economic
status is far higher than that for your
health statuses on a commercial and it's
just an easy to hear Sankri such a
success you distorted once again
apologize and say as I giving the
talking you talk about who you are
Philadelphia mostly urban centers I saw
so many parallels and kinds of things
ever seen
d so far back that black American one
question has to be partnered with racism
not much what you're experiencing in
your Asian community do you feel but
they have its origin origin OBCs
institutional racism here well that's a
very good question I think every group
has prejudice and remove has prejudice
and oftentimes you think about the
lumber all patients together and
actually this is each community's quite
congregate and isolated Chinese often
times do not work well with the Koreans
North Vietnamese but oftentimes I think
these are barriers are where a victim of
our own culture and racism does exist
even we don't use that term on the
language and so is prejudice and we
often look at people who don't have
insurance and will people have insurance
for in this higher socioeconomic status
and Moses acknowledged says definitely
there in terms of health care are not
the same and also the quality of care of
the same and oftentimes we see people do
not help in health insurance even they
come to the ethnic communities clinics
and we'll have the ethnic physicians if
you do not have health insurance you are
not able to be treated the same way and
oftentimes you have to have your cash on
the table before you your appointment to
to be consulted so I I think your
question is is really very valid and I
do believe there are prejudiced even
within the group and of course across
ethnic populations often times also
existing and that was paid a role in the
health care system yeah but I think the
reason why I asked that question has is
mostly do with the fact that as you see
your population increase in the right
time what if even kid other minority
groups who may happen to reside at the
same communities they talk about I'm not
specifically the early centered right
now that we may be able to do to be able
to effect the kind of change that human
population yes I I wanted to really use
that as a very new image is a very good
example oftentimes we look at the model
program that has been very successful in
the african-american community as well
as Latino so for example the Asian
community Cancer Network we started in
two thousand and but these programs has
already existing in the african-american
community as you recall National
Leadership Program dice started in back
in early 90s and the National Latino
program has started in 1950s so we
actually coming in as a much you know
later time but the weirdest level and
the program development we learned a lot
from the programs that has already
demonstrated success of course each
community has its own unique
characteristics so we adapt and we learn
and also oftentimes in our community
advisory board not only we have Asian
community leaders we also invite
african-americans as well as Latino
community leaders I think there
a lot of things we could share and the
learn from one another yeah that's
working for me however other questions
thank you I got the map thank you for a
very informative presentation okay I was
wondering about similar question which
is wondering about whether your research
looks at the role of stress and coping
help outcomes and in particular i'm
interested in the impact of the culprit
of stress especially given that much of
your population ninety percent are good
enough for her even those who've been
here for a long time Eroica lot of
stress so that's my first question and
the second question has to do with issue
that both you raise which is that the
statement was that we know that making
cultural adaptations to interventions
results in improve well we know for
short results in improved engagement and
retention but but possibly impacting
outcomes I wonder if you have any data
to support that because it's often a
clean that is challenged in the field
which is cultural annotations all right
I'll scary beaten right right well I
wanted to answer a second question first
in terms of the cultured outpatient I
think dr. deployment has put out a very
nice framework and oftentimes you know
even the culture change you know it's
even their support refuse and that you
you do enough of needs assessment focus
group were you get enough input from the
community as time goes by the culture
has changed I think how that would
tailored toward not only at the group
level but
by the individual level for example and
when we doing smoking cessation among
the Koreans the culture is very
different from what we do with the
Chinese and sometimes because of the
male macho you know mentality they do
not want their life to know they've
already thinking about being because
smoking is associated with certain the
adulthood and man mentor so these are
the things that often times and as
direct implementation we do ask our
clients and also the smokers and coming
in to see if these are the culture
issues that they would feel is its
effective as a sort of consumer and and
this this is a part of that we have been
keep on changing and testing and
oftentimes we do use the measurements
and variables are being already proved
the validating and validated in other
ethnic groups or we were in it to the
asian populations the question doesn't
mean anything to them so we have to
change the questions in the sort of the
cultural context in in the situation
culture that they are familiar with for
example where we talked about the cost
of smoking and we will now use examples
about the tax or we have to talk about
you you too now smoke you can save a
ticket for go to Korea go to China so
you put in the context that they can
relate and they can so sit with and the
in terms of when we have any data to
support I think we do have some
intervention publications already
demonstrated the outcome effectiveness
and which we're trying to look at the
variables and
where the knowledge that woman also
believe attitudes and behavior changes
at the different stages and you know not
only at the post-test but also three
months six months and twelve months and
this are sort of giving us a some
promising impact but the culture
adaptation as i mentioned each time and
each study and we have to sort of
continue to modify to tailor toward a
population we work with and in the
incense that we're trying to use the
evidence-based intervention not only
tested in other population but also
tested in our population for example
those are ones we got the received from
an age we have adapted the health belief
model of social cognitive model but a
lot of times these measurements are
already changed and it's way over how to
ask patients and the intervention
contents are have changed however the
framework is there major principles are
still there so that's where how we do
the dap tation and so is still very
challenging and it takes time to really
prove it works for the population and
i'm sure we have a long way to go and I
really see this as a beginning and of
our journey in working with the asian
population this is a such an your hair
it has not been focused on at different
level yeah excellent and do another
question too
it's too than happen it socially yes
hi back thank you for your presentation
I have a general question where you
cited by beautiful gaze up the ninety
percent on most recent immigrants and
I'm particularly curious about the
different generations looking back
specifically for the Chinese American
community communities that have been
here and have a longer history back five
generations which generations going down
to Louisiana to Filipino masher and
we're looking at that the health
implications that go along for those
generations had there been any studies
are there any plans for your Center to
really look at that and just try it and
try it out and map that right pattern
and incorporating this question about
acculturation and how it's different I
think that's a very good question we
have done some baseline studies trying
to look at you know the smoking
behaviors and cancer early detection
behaviors how the culture cultivation
factors would impact on these behaviors
but in terms of the intervention we have
not focus on that because one of the
reasons is we're looking at majority of
the Asian populations are foreign-born
and especially when you look at ethnic
minority health disparities and these
are issues often occur among the most
underserved and also ensured a low
income as well as the people who have
limited English proficiency however I
think your question is very valid
because in terms of this community we do
need to look at this the diet the
diversity and the variations among
different generations and groups and we
have not particularly look at English
speaking Chinese or people will have
been here for several generations and
oftentimes this could be another
stereotype when we look at the
demographics and people will have in
here
will have higher education there they're
more likely to have you no insurance and
have better resources to seek healthcare
and but not necessarily among people who
have been living here for 40 50 years
but they have always lived in Chinatown
they're always living in their own
communities so even the conservation has
been you know a very different among
people were living the ministry and also
those which is to live in their isolated
communities that is a very interesting
area we should again thank you okay well
three words and what you share is really
the ideal kind of model where a
researcher is not only doing work
regionally but nationally as well as
slowly internationally so we have now we
have doctor reported bird
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu